no one is last outing
when five at a third
a comfortable bend through his first
five innings and he said
he just hung a couple of curve balls in
the sixth inning the big one was to
aguilar the curveball second straight
pitch out over the plate he hit for a
two run home run yeah that's the pitch
he's going to need to throw tonight to
keep these yankees hitters off stride
what a pain in the neck dj le mayhew has
been her ball out into right center
field
harper says he has it he does one out i
told you we'd get him out tom about time
aaron judge the batter and a strike
three called on the outside corner that
got almost all of the plate just a
little delayed call from dan molino two
outs
swinging i miss curveball got him a
couple of strikeouts in the inning for
aaron nolda back to back to start things
here in the first jonathan lewis again
on the bump
in philly and on the season six and he's
pitched only three hits seven strikeouts
are pretty good
posing average 158 his stuff is really
good well above average and life and
velocity
here is gregorius batting in the cleanup
spot swinging a bouncer back towards the
mount lewis got it to second there's one
though to first is
in time
over at first base as the yankees turn
two the phillies want to just make sure
and they say take a look at it all right
so the phillies will challenge this one
i'm going to say he's safe
safe at first all right good call ben
good hustle deedee yeah fielder's choice
so first and third
and gene segura is coming up he's a
roller dive by glamour it's short passes
it to la mayhew and second they get dede
for the out a diving stop by gleber
torres to retire the side
known as curveball lying into left field
you can forget this one oh this is a
bomb
adios amigo
oh what a shot by boy it is one nothing
yanks
that breaking pole was right there over
the plate the fields have a man in
scoring position for andrew knapp that
one's looped out toward right center
field that's going to drop in for a hit
walker's around third heading for home
the throw to the plate not in time the
throw to second off the glove of torres
it's an rbi single for nap
it's a one-one game
that in a thousand with a stake no big
deal
another really good o2 approach here by
philly batter
in the air to right field judge going
back toward the track reaches out makes
the grab the side is retired
walker well the double whose first time
up
swings and grounds one to the right side
le mayhew stretches makes to play and
throws him out at first oh what a play
by dj le mayhew a full out stretch
and was able to get walker to retire the
side and noah back up on the hill to
face mike talkman there's the curveball
swung on and missed nine k's
for aaron nola and that had some depth
to it gary sanchez struck out his first
time up sway gonna miss it's the 13th
time in aaron noah's career he has
reached double digits in strikeouts and
here is on duhar too he tries to check
his swing they'll appeal he went around
says first base umpire nick lentz it's
another strikeout for erin noah his 11th
of the ball game he strikes out the side
around the single by her shella here in
the fifth five innings 11 strikeouts for
noah the only run was the home run back
in the second he has 18 swinging strikes
it's the most of the game since
september of 2018 for nolan well that'll
bring up labor torres who has struck out
twice tonight swinging a miss he struck
him out it's a dozen strikeouts for
aaron nola to match a career high so the
yankees with first and second nobody out
and mike talkman with a chance to put
his team ahead line drive they face it
to right center field stanton scores
easily moving to third is wade and the
yankees have taken a two to one lead on
the double by talkman bases are loaded
no one out and the yanks can put this
one away here with a big hit line drive
it's a base hit in front of harper wade
scores
and they hold talkman at third an rbi
single for urchella and it's 3-1 and
instead andrew mccutchen
is going to pitch it
for jay bruce
rolling ashore
labor's got it throws mccutchen out nice
play by gleber going to his right
and mccutcheon is gone for the first out
of the night britain is 2-1
it's guide to right
judge doesn't have to move
makes the catch
kingry is gone
and the acts run out of way
ground ball with tours this should do it
and it does as the yankees win this one
three to one as britain goes one two
three in the seventh inning